c'est précisément dans cette zone qu'un
journaliste français a trouvé la mort
hier alors qu'il accompagnait des civils
à bord d'un convoi humanitaire frédéric
leclerc imhof il avait trente deux ans
il couvrait derrière la caméra ce
conflit pour bfm tv il a été touché par
un éclat d'obus alors qu'il circulait à
bord d'un camion blindé le journaliste
reporter d'image est décédé sur le coup
le reporter qui l'accompagnait sains et
saufs tout comme leur fixeuse ils
doivent gagner dans les heures qui
viennent l'ouest de l'ukraine
l'occasion pour nous de revenir sur la
situation des journalistes sur le
terrain avec cyril payen d'un grand
reporter bonjour si vous êtes rentré
l'année dernière d'ukraine
vous étalez plusieurs reprises depuis le
début de ce conflit et vous pouvez nous
témoigner des difficultés à couvrir
cette guerre ont aujourd'hui un terrain
extrêmement difficile au style même
parfois aux journalistes oui puisque
c'est aussi on est au coeur d'une guerre
informationnelle entre les deux camps
évidemment avec une propagande qui s'est
d'ailleurs rappelé immédiatement après
la mort tragique de notre confrère hier
par le biais de l'agent stas l'agencé
officielle russe qui a eu quand même là
le set accède propagande ou de cynisme
on ne sait pas comment décrire et
d'affirmer donc qu'ils avaient les
preuves qu'il s'agissait non pas d'un
journaliste mais d'un mercenaire qui
livré des armes aux forces ukrainienne
donc voilà on se trouve voilà où quand
quelle réalité on se trouve et la
réalité qui est bien sûr revenu
pour nous tous qui couvrent on s'est
tassée en droit dans cette guerre avec
la mort de ce jeune 2e confrères c'est
qu'en fait on est très exposé on est
dans une guerre conventionnelle ce
n'était pas prévu on pensait que avec la
fin de la seconde guerre mondiale on
n'aurait pas avoir des tels le père dé
tel taux de dévastation dans le dombass
où la guerre fait rage
on parle d'un dans des les pertes
craignent un d'un ratio de 60 à 100 aux
hommes par jour qui meurt donc on est
vraiment dans une
dans une échelle absolument colossal
encore une fois dont on pensait qu'on
allait tourner la page et dont on
pensait aussi que nous journalistes
n'aurions pas à les couvrir avec les
pertes de reporters sans frontières
parle de huit morts avérés mais il
s'agirait plus de 24 morts puisqu'il ya
les enquêtes beaucoup de disparition et
des journalistes qui ont été visés là il
s'agit d'un impact c'était une un convoi
humanitaire alors déjà tiré sur un
convoi humanitaire mais le président
veut le dire c'est les hellènes ce qu'il
a rappelé la ministre des affaires
étrangères française hier elle a dit
rappelez-vous ce qu'a fait l'armée russe
à marioupol rappelez-vous les
évacuations que nous avons vécu dans la
grande banlieue de kiev il ya deux mois
où il est convoi était systématiquement
pris pour cible donc ça fait partie de
ces risques il n'y a pas de règle dans
les guerres conventionnelles il y à des
tirs d'artillerie des tirs de but mais
également des journalistes qui sont
visés puisque les les la plupart des
morts qui ont été
déplorés ce fait ces départs la bataille
dire pinet de boudhha il y à deux mois
avec des confrères qui ont été tués par
des snipers qui les visaient malgré
évidemment avoir tous les étendards les
attributs de presse des moyens de
protection donc cette les journalistes
sont ici en zone vulnérable à la petite
voilà le coup effectivement de façon
plus générale parce qu'on parle de
l'ukraine ici mais les journalistes sont
devenus ces derniers temps une cible oui
effectivement pas ce qu'il y à une
mondialisation de l'information donc on
est beaucoup plus sur le terrain il y a
quand même aussi une
professionnalisation je dois dire des
des combats des journalistes qui vont
sur les terrains de guerre notamment en
france les diamants la france 24
puisqu'on passe tous par une académie où
on apprend les réflexes de sécurité mais
ça devient aussi la norme pour beaucoup
de chaînes mais il ya beaucoup de monde
sur le terrain donc c'est presque
miraculeux je dirais qu'il n'y ait pas
plus de morts à déplorer sur un terrain
comme le cren mais au delà de l'ukraine
parlant par exemple de jérusalem où une
grande journaliste de la chaîne al
jazeera a été sans doute selon les
enquêtes locales les enquêtes d'autres
chaînes de télévision étaient visés par
des tirs de snipers dans le camp de
jénine il y a trois semaines notre
consoeur les lao des parce qu'elle
couvrait
il y a quelques jours et bien une
manifestation porte de damas et bien été
également violente et donc on est
effectivement aussi pris à partie entre
les lacets sherlyn charline à bout à
claques qui a été qui a été tuées dont
on sait que c'est un tir de sniper
israélien donc ce n'est pas du tout un
hasard c'est une collatéral mais qui
était visé donc il ya vraiment une
inflexion aussi a porté sur le rôle des
journalistes dans les zones de guerre
les lahoud et c'était avant-hier notre
consoeur du service arabe de de france
24 qui a le tort par rapport aux
manifestants d'être elle-même
palestinienne donc en fait oui il y à
une réflexion certainement apporter sur
le journalisme de guerre sur la présence
des journalistes en a évidemment tout
cela ne doit pas s'arrêter mais il ya
une prise de position et puis je veux
aussi parler des de la guerre
informationnelle lancé par la russie qui
nous touche nous français beaucoup avec
des trolls une énorme propagande sur
internet donc tout ça fait partie du
quotidien de beaucoup de journalistes
aujourd'hui avec hélas hélas des fins
tragiques pour de jeunes confrères merci
beaucoup si elle payen de retour donc
parmi nous merci d'être passé par par le
plateau de paray direct on en vient